this is a closed crop and this is a very  in must tab right now summer style and  what makes it great is the fact that  it's low maintenance very short  what-you-see-is-what-you-get and it  really opens up the face and is a great  summer cut you want to get it tighter in  through here and in through the back and  leave a little length on top so very  important to to note that there's some  extra length here in the front this is  also an extremely easy haircut to a  style you take a little bit of pomade  about this much you want to start from  the front and move all the way to the  back before you start the styling then  from the back you're gonna move back to  the front make sure you get this side  you